und fragen wir nach bei herbert
bauernebel für uns in washington dc vor
dem weissen haus tag eins nach der
entlassung herbert hält sich denn der
präsident momentan an bi quarantäne oder
ist er schon wieder auf wahlkampftour
auf seinem terminkalender stehen keine
offiziellen termine natürlich dort hält
sich im weißen haus auf in den
privatgemächern aber er ist natürlich
sehr aktiv auf twitter
das ist ja eigentlich nichts neues
donald trump wird oft seine
amtsgeschäfte
via twitter und eben diesen umstrittenen
tweet abgesetzt mit dem vergleich zur
grippe wo er behauptet hat dass mehr als
100.000 amerikaner an der grippe sterben
in einer saison das ist natürlich über
eine völlig übertriebene zahl wie viele
experten sofort angemerkt haben es sind
in den schlimmsten grippe sondern
meistens nur um die 30 bis 40 tausend
menschen nur ist natürlich ein
umstrittenes wort demnach jedes jeder
todesfall ist natürlich tragisch aber
das ist ein neues beispiel
offensichtlich von einer neuerlichen
verbirgt taktik die donald trump iran
werden möchte um das carola virus
herunter zu spielen jetzt eben selbst
als person die das virus besiegt hat so
sieht er sich jedenfalls am programm
steht diesem tag auch noch seine fünfte
und letzte dosis des ebola mittels rem
dass wir das wird intravenös verabreicht
und man wird jetzt sehen wir in den
nächsten stunden noch weiter twittern
wird er hat jedenfalls eines
bekanntgegeben er möchte ganz bestimmt
teilnehmen
mitte oktober bei der zweiten tv debatte
gegen seinen rap gegen seinen
demokratischen rivalen joe biden mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bet schaut euch hier das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren